as always the episode is brought to you
by a gray block pizza 18:11 Pico
Boulevard on the way to the beach you
know if you've seen me recently you know
that I got um you know you know I got
that wild boy hairstyle you know you got
you know yo I got that human alpaca you
know I'm saying on that freakin I'm not
shy I'm s I'm that five foot eleven shag
carpet bag daddy you know what I'm
saying you know I got that you know what
I'm saying you see me comb and you see
me part and they tryna catch me hair and
naughty
you know how I'm doing with that hair
hair and the thing how I do my hair
these days is you know they out of Aqua
Net when I was young we used to use that
Aqua Net boy dude Aqua Net you could do
anything bro you could seal if you
didn't have fix-a-flat and your tire
went out BAM boy put a can of that net
right up against that rubber you know
that rubber tire better man that tire
never bust again
that tire never bust again that's how I
could go to church boy that tire would
be in styling Aqua Net was crazy man you
could make a little flamethrower at the
house if you wanted to you know maybe
you had a disgruntled lover and you want
to torch that house get you a little
birthday candle you know out there a lit
but they can don't get you a can Aquanet
hairspray and your home burn it down
burn it down that's what you could do
with that Aqua Net and they had that man
you can't even get a can of Aqua Net
anymore nowadays if you want to get a
can Aqua Net you need to go behind like
a Staples or something and see a couple
of little bad boys back there being
naughty
you know maybe three or four men back
there playing you know you know playing
cream horn or something or something
wild like that you know playing a
snickerdoodle with each other's bodies
you know playing uh you know looking for
lemon meringues in the back of each
other's throats and and those are the
kind of people that might have a can of
that a that a in that Ocwen
net and aqua net worths man I mean you
could dude it was the original taxidermy
product nowadays they got a lot of
taxidermists out there you know I got a
buddy out there mr. Duncan his a
taxidermist he's out there Derman out on
them squirrels and all of that you know
I'm saying and [ __ ] anytime you're
using a paintbrush on a raccoons [ __ ]
you know that you that ain't work you
know I won't consider that work if we're
really talking about taxidermy taxidermy
you out there you know I'm saying any
time you put in the finishing touches on
a UH on a baby walrus dick I don't
consider that that ain't heart you know
I'm saying you got there vert and boy
you out there a pervert you know mother
you know mother nature ain't hiring you
to put the finishing touches on her
products you got there playing with
let's be honest if you do endure me if
you out there in them derm dermis you
know then you are them you that's the
dark arts you know I'm saying anytime
you out there you know you just
massaging the nostrils of a [ __ ]
senior citizen raccoon to get it just
right because you're a taxidermist cam L
never ain't even proper and you know it
but Aqua Net was the original if you
wanted to do taxidermy and you couldn't
you know or if you were like say you had
a you know you would just hit an animal
with that net hit him with that
hairspray and that thing was stuck like
that you could catch a bass and just
spray it down with that Aqua Net put it
on the wall but jam and now you have
that beautiful you know you have that
piece that people can see me like oh
he's got abilities he's got you know
fisherman capabilities like that but now
if you if you don't have an Aqua Net
also say if you were at the house and
you know they had a lady in our
neighborhood missa Gretch and miss
grudge had a well she actually had a
panther that killed her cousin
right and but that's because he was
trying to throw a surprise party and I
mean you don't throw a surprise party
around a panther everybody knows that
[ __ ]
okay the last here's the last thing you
do around a panther is jump out from
behind a piece of furniture and yell
surprise okay because that is uh that is
exhibit a for you're about to die to a
Panther so so anyway they but she had a
broken window in her house you know she
had a one front window and that thing
was broke out you know because her and
her husband and got in a fight and uh
and he threw a lawnmower through it and
here's the crazy thing you don't think a
lawnmower go through a front window well
it will but the thing was though she had
a cat after that and the cat would um
and it had it was like a big hair cat
one of those I don't know what they're
called um you know uh you know a fluffer
or something one of those big ball look
like you're [ __ ] chubby ant you ever
have a chubby ant and maybe she's
Italian or something or you know she got
that Pomeranian she got so much hair but
she had a cat like that and it had big
hair and the window so she what she
would do the window wasn't too big so
what she would do she spray that cat
down with that hairspray and get a tear
as wide as it could and then the cat had
to couldn't get out the window literally
the hair when he would try to get out
his hair would be too hard and it would
stop him hmm so that was uh so back in
the day you know if you had to keep an
animal in a in a house then you would
spray it up and get its hair big and it
would be kind of confined they call that
confined but those were the good old
days man but what I'm telling you right
now is that that nowadays from my hair
people wonder how I keep this swag
mystique you know and how I keep my swag
mystique is this you know and you hear
that beardbrand right there and be your
brain that's a premium
mens hair product okay I'm using that
old money sea salt spray and I'm gonna
few familiar with this style but it's
like Poseidon just spit in a damn Little
Chute bottle and you just fire this
thing in your hair boy Oh
Poseidon just throwing that know they
not a front wash on to me and he put you
know mmm and it's tasty too it tastes
like you butter mmm it tastes like you
just like you just tangled tongues with
a damn starfish but beer brand is based
out of Austin Texas it encourages men to
be themselves they have a lot of great
products man they got that temple smoke
this beautiful little bomb you can put
onto a you know under your skin on your
hair just kind of adds texture it's
about adding texture and suave and sway
vation to yourself yeah you got to make
sure to grab that utility bomb that's
what I'm talking about it's great
anywhere you need be your hair skin you
know you could probably use it around
your cuticles if you harden it up around
the cutes if you get in real crispy and
them cute taste you know in the
fingernails you can get it it's a
moisturizing product that softens hair
breathes life into your skin into your
hair go to beardbrand comm slash Theo
today for a free sample of that sea salt
spray automatically added to your first
order it has texture it adds volume
everything at beardbrand does add to
yourself okay foster confidence through
grooming beat at beardbrand bad boy go
to beardbrand comm slash Theo today for
that free sea sea salt hitter a man look
I just want to say welcome to the show
man that was a long intro wasn't it but
hey hey hey that's where we are today
and you guys are a bunch of damn you
know I know you guys are a bunch of
saucy little caramels and everybody in
summer is just summer it's like just
fall starting to fall off the edge of
the it fall off a cliff into the past
summer is just falling away and all the
melons and them you know them fruit you
know the mom fruit salads and I love a
damn fruit salad bro think about a who
daughter that
fruit salad who said you know what who
and who cheers to them
cheers to the fruit salad brah that's
the Rosa Parks of recipes right there
because when you think somebody having a
salad in a salad it's basically like
dragging your mouth just it's like
somebody just opens your mouth and put
your arms out and you just drags you
through a garden you know it's dark
having a salad brought make you [ __ ]
just having a salad honestly make your
neck hurt a little but then somebody's
having a salad and they're like I know
what would be really good in a salad
[ __ ] fruit coconut raisins
marshmallow CBD all come on boy
now we talking fruit salad dude you have
to [ __ ] handfuls of fruit salad brah
you know I'm saying dude you'll
test-drive your stepmother dog if she's
down you know anything is possible do
you know how tough I can build a chimney
bro I put a chimney onto a damn outhouse
dude yeah we [ __ ] and [ __ ] you
know we burning logs everywhere in this
sucker we you know we got that doodoo
going in that we making heat you know
I'll do anything I'll [ __ ] right into a
fireplace bro and cook it up you know
I'm saying and that's that power of
fruit salad sorry I know I got off off
the beaten path there anyway man I just
want to say welcome to the show welcome
to this past weekend remember to soul
tune man do you remember the this one
right here
this past weekend that was that intro
man that original intro right there and
I want to say welcome man you know and
here we go welcome to this past weekend
[Music]
celebrate man
[Music]
celebrate our
[Music]
Oh
come on
let's have some fun while we all die and
that's a Spencer Jacob growl band right
there and they're doing it right and
that is their song celebrate and thank
you guys for being here with me today oh
man I had a wild weekend you know I got
I got moving you know I found I look I
mean on a couple levels I got my
motivation going this weekend you know I
went running I'll come if you've been
running or not but I mean it was dude
you get out there that first run if you
haven't ran in a while you know cuz I've
been more of this year I've been more of
like a walker you know or loitering
maybe loitering quickly I'll give myself
that but I've been more of that kind of
you know one step at a time you know
what I'm saying I don't want to do too
much with my feet and legs and knees all
at once but I got out there and went for
a run put on some Arrowsmith I put on
some Aerosmith I listen to that Joe
Rogan and Elon Musk dude I thought that
world was gonna blow up bruh do it I was
can you imagine listen and I imagine to
somebody somewhere to eat in a Little
Debbie moon pie getting a blow job at a
crop at a Chrysler Pontiac dealer ship
now that's how to listen to that one you
know a little bit of weed smoke in the
air and you having one of them a Little
Debbie bad boy hitter so you know taking
one of them you know them them sugary no
nose right into your [ __ ] any uh any
air valve bra you know right into that
[ __ ] meat sucker that throat and
you're getting a [ __ ] of it air at
that Pontiac Chrysler dealership and in
the background you got a LAN musk and
Joe Rogan going on whoo but yeah I hit
the I just hit the streets man in my
legs they felt like rentals I'm here
I've been on that first run but your leg
feel like damn is it one of them was
automatic when I was a stick shift I'm
just out there like
I'm complaining about [ __ ] him like this
they got too many potholes in the city I
was losing it man
but I did it dude and here's why I did
it man I wasn't feeling that good and so
I was like I gotta find my own
motivation I have to get out there and
so that's what I did I hit that block
you know I got that MA got maybe some my
a little bit uh you know I just and then
the second day I went again and then it
felt easier like damn I'm fast and dude
how my brain works the first day I'm
like wow this is [ __ ] you know dude
in a wheelchair past me you know I'm
sounding like you cheatin bruh you know
but that second day I started cruising
the second day I'm like my brain starts
thinking oh do you should do a 10k bro
you should do a 12 K you know you should
do K through 12 and then I'm telling my
brain I'm like that's uh that's a
illegal the third one is illegal but
yeah that's my brain man one day I can
barely run the second day I'll get a
little faster and the third day my
brains telling me damn dog you know you
should be you know you could be that
white Carl Lewis you could be that white
Carl Lewis dude or that white um you
know II dress elbow he's so but yeah I
went for a run I felt good man I got
back in it I got back in action that's
what I did and the rest of my life hit
my brain he started to follow suit you
got to get your blood moving if you're a
bloody movin man come on because blood
is what's inside of us dude you know
blood is mother nature's saliva bra and
imagine if Mother Nature just sits there
all day with saliva in her mouth
that's nasty but if mother nature starts
swishing that stuff around boy
anything's possible dude
she'll spit a pearl out in the air she
you know anything's possible but that
was good man I went for a run I got
cruising I um oh I went to dr. Drew's
birthday party last week and dr. drew I
don't
you know him he is a you know he's a
medical professional but he is also kind
of a you know like a chat like he works
with Adam Carolla's on the Adam
Carolla's show and they are you know a
couple of kind of Chatty bad boys and
Adam kind of talks like you about how he
knows everything but dr. Drew actually
does know everything so it's really fun
being around those dudes because it's I
don't know they just you know Adam
always tells dr. Drew to kind of pipe
down but dr. Drew's the one with the
information you know an Adam was a
construction worker and then something
happened to him or something and I think
he got workman's comp and and then
started podcasting you know but they're
both beautiful guys and dr. Drew had a
60th birthday party so I'll win over
there and Geney boss was there she was
on here remember Cheney bus came in here
and uh-oh here's what she told me she
said that since she came on here a lot
of men been hitting her up on Instagram
and she even went on a date with one of
them so look at that we're making love
out there and I wanted to see if maybe
they had done a little bit of that you
know that my my my my my mom you know
that bang I that bang bang but but she
didn't give me all that you know she's a
lady
and she didn't you know get me like that
and tell me all of it but that was like
pretty cool like wow we had her and we
talked to her and then now she's out
there you know she you know she was
dating a guy from the Verizon shop [ __ ]
she might you know she might date a damn
sandwich artist you know she might date
a [ __ ] Quiznos chef next who know
whose bra they're you could be
unemployed there long as you could
juggle and get her attention you might
have a shot with the beautiful
Jeannie bus but the you know the party
was pretty cool I saw you know and I
don't like dr. Drew's kind of thing in
his wife Susan Penske she's great man
and they're just a beautiful couple and
you know I'll say this about dr. drew
man he has always been
um I've you know those people you meet
in this business you're like man this
dude as a straight Mulan you know this
Mook right here
you know this guy's just out for himself
he doesn't care but dr. Drew not never
you always get the feeling like he
generally you know yes he's in the
entertainment industry and this and that
but that he cares about other people and
that he feels a responsibility in the
world with his knowledge to help others
and is pretty cool ma'am
and you get that feeling from and and
that's what I trust the most inside of
me is my instincts because my instincts
are from a long time ago you know that's
the thing about instincts your instincts
are brain or it's like it's like you're
the brain of your grandparents and your
their grandparents and you know and
you're super super super pop-pop and
whoever you know and mee-mah mee-mah
mee-mah in your great-great ancestors
and your grand ancestors and your
grizzly grizzly you know super freak
cave you know fancy pants stepdaddy's
and everybody it's your whole timeline
all their thoughts and all their
knowledge you're in that's what your
instincts are you know it said this that
you know you're like that stream that's
come off of all of their knowledge and
their their experiences so that's what
our instincts are not oh and I trust my
instincts mostly you know sometime you
have a lot of what is it people like
Sherlock Holmes and Sherlock Holmes is
armed
he's British you know so they dressed
like they do but he has uh you know one
of those ant burners those things they
used to burn ants and he's always
holding it over his eye and stuff like
that and but he looks for clues you know
he's a clue boy you know hints and eye
clues I call clues honestly cheating
because I do instincts only bro you know
what I'm saying there's somebody dead in
the middle of the room office and
there's nine other people in the room
standing around the body and the lights
were off and it just came on in the dead
bodies right there on the floor with a
knife and its back
I roll right up in that [ __ ] and I'm
like [ __ ] Daniel did it and that's it
bro when we take Daniel out back dude
and that's that because you got to trust
those instincts man your instincts
they're basically uh you know it's a
whole history of experience that's
trying to help you out so if your
instincts are calibrated pretty well
that can be really be helpful I think so
anyway but dr. drew man I've always
gotten great instincts from that guy and
I've I just felt blessed even know that
man and his lovely wife we had a good
time but they had a podcast at the
birthday party so you want to talk to
people and mill around and they got a
podcast going on so you can go check out
the episode I thought honestly one of
the worst ideas I'd ever seen in my life
I'm like wow that's what everybody wants
to have fun but they got a huge and the
podcast is happenin live and it was cool
and look I got to I was a guest for you
know yeah they just recycled through gas
and everybody stopped in and said hey
and and it was nice to be a part of it I
felt honored and I guess it doesn't
matter what I think you know that I
thought it was aggravating because it's
not my [ __ ] party you know I was a
guest it's his party
it's his white state sit there event
what does it matter what I mean I you
know that's what sometimes about me out
that's one of the things sometimes I'll
be like Manny's [ __ ] sucks who gives
a [ __ ] well you're a guest to somebody
else who don't suck this might be their
you know this might be their sing you
know their magnum opus this might be
their uh you know kit and kaboodle and
to you it's just yarn so but it was you
know it was a unique experience who else
was there
oh uh that tall guy with the spiky hair
who did talk soup Joel McHale he was
there Tom Arnold was there yelling about
Donald Trump did it was so funny he
tried to make it an announcement about
Donald Trump at this birthday nobody
gave a [ __ ] brahh and i would love to
have tomorrow
here I'm gonna reach out to him and see
if he'll come on yeah apparently he's
been like searching on for some like
lost tape against Donald Trump that's
just everybody's just been laughing
about it I hear but um who else Stevo
was there that was pretty cool to see
Steve you know he's I was like and I
don't know and that was a loss Oh Bob
Saget was there you know but it was fun
man I was honored to be there and uh and
it was kind of fancy to see no dress
enough and people are there and I just
felt kind of honored to be a part of it
Oh what else is going on him here I Oh
[ __ ] up gun was in town so I went to
see Bishop gun man we went out there we
had a nice time met a couple of met this
beautiful crew from Bakersfield some
nice people over there
I thought we took a picture maybe they
never sent it to me but but yeah some we
they had a couple of my boy hey soos who
listens to the podcast he brought his
lady out you know sat with them for a
little bit and had a little Long Island
iced tea and what else and enjoyed the
music man they rocked it they rocked it
out they did two nights at the
Troubadour and one night at the mint in
Los Angeles dude and then they came to
the comedy store after and the lead
singer Travis or tear avis some people
say it tear Avis but I think it's
pronounced Travis he had on the he look
like a dam he look like a Fraggle that
had been through a domestic dispute and
he look he had on this huge it looked
like it looked kind of like a like the
abominable snowman had got caught up at
out like a EDM concert you know and had
done a lot of Molly and maybe [ __ ] you
know uh done a little too much acid and
just lost his mind at a sherwin-williams
you know he was like all cut just this
colorful big I mean I'm dude if he if he
would have been forty more miles outside
of the city limits somebody would have
gun that dude down and thought that they
had just you know just shot
Devils Doberman you know hit was like
that so that was you know it was just
cool to see to see them and they came
out and we had a good time and we had a
good time over there went in started we
saw them perform and it felt good you
listen to those songs so that was it man
that was really my weekend you know you
know I was thinking a lot about - you
know I was thinking a lot about like
motivation and stuff this week anyway
and what where that comes from I was
thinking about like in our time like in
my lifetimes they've had you know we've
kind of lost like you can't really fail
anymore I mean you can fail but we've
kind of built this work this society in
America that that you'll be taking care
of you know like if you lose your job
you can sit at the house for a while
next thing you know what thing comes in
the mail says oh you're unemployed you
can collect unemployment oh okay
cool now collect unemployment right you
could be in a house you get you know
evicted next thing you know you can
maybe get a mobile mobile home if you
could take your house with you now you
get a halfway house you get half of a
house you know you can get apartment you
can get a four-plex like it there you
could get a tent in LA there's four
dudes living in just on the street like
literally 30 feet from my apartment
there's four tents in the park behind my
apartment complex there's probably I bet
there's a hundred tents in there people
living in there too intense you know
it's like you you could just keep kind
of going through the system you know
like you can like I feel like a long
time ago it would be like and I guess
the tents that's like actually being
homeless but it's like we kind of built
this society where it's you have you
have to make your own motivation because
it used to just seem like back in the
day like in the Great Depression or you
know Benedict Arnold or something like
that or you know if there was like a big
flood or anything like you
you might die you might die so there was
this thing inside of your head that you
know this fight-or-flight kind of thing
that like got you up every morning you
had a pat you know like you had to
survive like the survival instinct was
alive inside of us and because it needed
it it needed to be there it was like a
pilot light like on your heater
downstairs that he's on your water
heater it was that pilot light to
survive was in us but now in America
anyway it feels like survival is it's
kind of grant like we're kind of we've
become grandfathered into it you know
it's cool it's almost guaranteed and I
know I'm not saying that there's not
like you know addiction and things like
that that can really take people off
their course you know but outside of
addiction and mental illness you can
you'll always be taking care of kind of
an America so I wonder if that's
starting to like kill our survival
instinct that's inside of us you know
and I think about that like because I
start thinking you know one thing I
always loved was be like I've always
loved in my life was just feeling like
the underdog you know just that survivor
instinct that thing like you know that
dirty little M&M that you know that but
that Marshall Mathers that lived in the
base your brain you know they do you
know that thing that got you like you
know I got this I can take care of me I
will survive because you had to I felt
like a little bit more when I was
growing up but now it's gotten a little
more like oh everybody's gonna survive
you know the government everyone will be
taken care of there will be a stipend
everybody wolf and I'm not saying that
that's wrong but I'm saying that that's
killed that survival instinct and that
that pilot light inside of us that like
I feel like that's killed it you know
like so now you got to find your own
motivation you got a fine and that's why
I think there's so many things out there
that like motivation is such a big thing
now because we got to find our own motor
vation we got to find it because them
that pilot like that was in our brain
that was our motivation that thing it's
it in one it doesn't want to burn bright
if it knows that everything's gonna be
okay
fight or flight or just you know you
know catch this check off the Guffey and
[ __ ] you know post up at the Days Inn
for a month you know I'm out here I
eaten you know being you know being a
freakin bad boy out here at the Hampton
Inn you know out here you know buying
cross leather off the internet buying
fake crushed leather it's like there's
nothing to take care it's like we don't
need that this survival instinct is it's
become sedated in America because we
don't need it
we don't need it as much anymore and
what I'm saying is I got to remind
myself since we're in a time where it's
like everybody gets taken care of no
matter what which I'm not saying it's
wrong but I'm saying it kills a little
bit of the humanity in us that you know
that drive because that that that drive
it's like that's reactionary you know
that's that fight-or-flight and I feel
like now the reason there is so much
motivational stuff out there is because
we need it as humans because there's a
net under us all the time now you know
you don't see that trapeze bad boy you
know a dude out there in tights you know
the little Larry gets out there for the
first time in tights trying to trapeze
you know he comes off that first that
first swing going for the second and he
misses that [ __ ] you know the next
thing you know he gets all you know he
gets remodeled by the earth the next
thing you know the elbows connected to -
you know - spleen
he's remodeled because there was known
there was there used to be no net there
you could [ __ ] if you didn't take
care of yourself who knows what happened
you know you got kicked out the house
there wasn't maybe there wasn't any
government assistance next thing you
know you're in a mental health facility
next to no you wander outside of there
and they got another dude who's homeless
out in the woods he been shooting
out there you take a freaking you know
you take one that was Native American
[ __ ] you know that the arrow
basically the number-two pencil from a
Native American right into the neck and
you're out
but now there's the net so you know
Larry with them wild hips that trapeze
freaking future you know fancy pants he
could try a million times he'll be fine
so he got a he has to create his own
motivation we have to create our own
motivations now and so that's just you
know some of the things I've been
realizing like that fighter flight that
was in me when I was young some of that
when I was a child I think someone has
to go on you know I'm being a child did
around this time of year when the I used
to love that man when the autumn came in
boy mmm-hmm and Ally started to fall off
the trees and you'd be running around
outside and catch them in your mouth
Brent you and your friend out there you
know just being a couple of [ __ ] just
fish and just just catching leaves in
your mouth and you know we used to do
this little game I remember we had a
plastic bowl or somebody had a plastic
bowl by us they had a lady down the
street he used to bang her she was a
substitute teacher and she used to hook
up with a couple of her students and um
but anyway she give us this plastic bowl
of we put it out in the yard me and her
son and her son was really key in the
jowls you know he was real you know I
don't know his bottom lip really did its
job cuz he had just saliva coming out
you know that little geyser
you know he's that little local geyser
like if you wanted a male saw a bunch of
letters you go by him and just rub a
stamp on his cheek and just put it right
on the thing you know he was that little
[ __ ] walking lick lick and so we get
out there and we'd try to catch these
leaves in our mouth and put them into
the bowl you know when we do our hands
behind our back or time behind our back
with some rope or something and um and
then we'd get the leaves and put them
into the bowl and he was all you know
he had that drippy you know his mind has
a whole face was all slicked his whole
hit dude he would drool upwards he had
this dude could [ __ ] drool he would
drool upwards it would drool the drool
would go up down and up
you know like gravity didn't even work
right by his face and he would drool
down and up and the good his whole face
would be wet and I'd have to catch the
league's in my at the leaves in my mouth
you know it would be autumn time and the
leave were coming off the trees and I'd
have to catch him on my mouth naturally
you know because I only had just had
moisture inside of my mouth and I had a
little bit of oily skin you know but um
because we grew up we were literally
right by um like a like a um I guess one
of this place where they would paint
cars or maybe they were just stealing
cars and painting get rid of him but a
lot of some of the oil-based paints and
stuff they were using over there that
oil would get in the air when they were
using those guns and it would get you
know it would stay on us for a couple of
months if they were really doing a big
paint job over there but anyhow the the
boy in my neighbor his hole he'd have
drooled all up and his whole face would
be all shiny shiny and it looked like
he'd been in a fire and they put salve
on him but that was just his natural you
know that was just his natural gut
moisture that saliva drool and he so he
could catch all the leaves dude he'd run
around and get all the leaves to leave
would hit him and he kept it would just
stick on his face just you know so he'd
have about 40 [ __ ] leaves dude and uh
and I have to catch one at a time in my
mouth so he was always cheating a little
bit cuz I to get one at a time
but he have like 40 or 50 and then one
time he scared this dog man they had a
Rottweiler to live by us who allegedly
and am I saying this is true but killed
one of my favorite cafeteria workers
once and this Rottweiler week when we
would do stuff outdoors he would get
nervous because he didn't have a leash
or a chain or anything he just lived in
the neighborhood I don't know where he
lived at I bet he had a nice [ __ ]
house dude this [ __ ] look like
he had two bedroom too bad you know
and a couple little kids did I wouldn't
be surprised if this Rottweiler had
human children because he was that you
know he has shoulders on him he had a
[ __ ] you know it looked like he
listened to NWA you know I'm young his
wit attitude and did all of that
wildness but he one time came when um
when this boy got all the moisture on
his face all over and hit so many leaves
it scared that dog and that dog [ __ ]
came and bit him right in the back so
but the goal was to get as many leaves
as you could into the bowl that was
actual game I'll tell you about this man
if you thinking about a game a good game
is this one right here unruly bastards
because that's what we were for sure you
know when you got a drool you know one
little drool baby you know that little
drippy infant he's running around you
know you got a you're an unruly bastard
but unruly bastards is a hilarious party
game it's a game for parties if you'd
like to be at a party and you don't have
anything to do you guys are standing
around just looking at each other
thinking about maybe being with each
other's wives or something but afraid to
ask
well now you could play a game called
unruly bastards and you pick a card it
has a theme on it this one says sexual
Olympic events so a sexual Olympic event
for me would be you know I would say
doing hurdles when you have staph
infection in your nutsack I think that
would hurt a little bit but this this is
there's all these cards it's super fun
it's simple to play is full of crazy
situations and characters it's live on
Kickstarter right now this is your
chance to get it and be the first to own
it it's only twenty bucks man that's a
nice party game you want to find out how
insane your friends really are you know
I'm saying they got all kind of stuff on
there
geriatric um geriatric care Mel makers
name seven of them you know I made that
one up but there's all type of good
options in there
this one says tipsy mom hitting on her
daughter's boyfriend
so you know that is that mom brings you
upstairs to her room you know something
what the white the Mama's wild you know
when you hooking up and they got a
painting of her children on the wall
that's that's when you know the Lord is
not you don't know the Lord as well as
you might want to but that's um that's a
game you can check out unruly bastards
go to unruly bastards calm and support
their Kickstarter they're creating a
game so really you're supporting them
and you get the game gang gang yeah
let's get to a few calls man that was
pretty much my weekend you know I'm
feeling more motivated I'm reelin I got
a fine I'm motivation because you know I
sometimes I think like you think it's
gonna be inside of you and it's not
inside of us as much anymore and that's
why I found myself looking to senior you
know people that are senior to me for
motivation because the motivation isn't
that fighter flight is not built in us
anymore
we're being nurtured in us in an
environment here I feel like and I could
be wrong I could be so wrong dude I'm
wrong about a lot of stuff not this hair
but I'm wrong about a lot of things but
I think we're being nurtured in a
society where we can't fail where you're
always going to get bailed out
oh you burnt your leg off here's another
leg oh you can't taste nothing anymore
you know you did too much drugs or you
as drinking bleach at the laundromat
well guess what we now we got a um we
got you this uh taste and I dog you know
we got you a taste dog and if you took
when you taste something he'll bark you
know if it tastes sweet he'll bark three
times you know if you taste something
and it's salty he'll bark once right
so now you got a taste you know uh you
know you got one of them Tet you know
them them you got one of them mom taste
bud Bichons and so oh oh you if he seven
times for caramel he'll bark seven times
I think that was only six but you know
what I'm saying you got a taste bud be
of a little animal Nate you did that's a
world we live in
oh you can't breathe we got a
can do two will stay in here next you
can breathe for you and tell you what
it's like like you can't fail anymore in
America you can fail but you can't feel
like you fail so we want the the you
know whatever it is and I don't and look
if you guys have thoughts on this hit
the hotline nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three but it's doubt that
that five that pilot light that's inside
of us that sink or swim if we always
know that every time we sink the bottom
is gonna get at the bottom is going to
come up and meet our feet the man at a
certain point the desire for us the fear
of sinking all the way it's gonna leave
our you know my children won't know it
because how would I ever instill it to
them if it doesn't exist so we have to
create our own motivations that's what
I'm saying the motivation is not going
to come within right now from us as much
as it's gonna start from with outside of
us you know the fight-or-flight instinct
now is to start outside of us and so
that's why we go to pee that's why I
listen to people like Coco Diaz and Joe
rogon's you know and who else Davy
Crockett that bad buoyant dude you try
to [ __ ] fight somebody in a Coonskin
cap and win him dude first of all they
had one dude used to sell raccoon penis
uh necklaces and they would beat his ass
all the time bro
can you imagine some dudes shows up in a
[ __ ] octopus swim cap saying he's
gonna defend the land somebody gonna
whoop his ass
so Davy Crockett doesn't get enough
credit because Davy Crockett was an
American super human the may think about
[ __ ] defending something while you
wearing a [ __ ] ostrich one-piece bra
so
buddy's gonna kick your ass you think
about what somebody comes in you're
working at a 7-eleven right you working
at a 7-eleven and somebody comes in and
holds a gun and you got a [ __ ] eel
you know you got a eelskin eye patch on
they're gonna [ __ ] shoot you man but
Davy Crockett wore the shadiest [ __ ] you
could wear a raccoon skin cap imagine
taking a cap off of an animal that plays
in the garbage and defending your nation
with it or defending your land or
whatever he defended I think he defended
like a um
I don't know what even what it was like
he might have done a drive-by shooting I
don't know what Davy Crockett did okay
because the government has taken away
some of the books but I do know that to
successfully defend something while
you're wearing something that everybody
wants to kill you for wearing because it
looks ridiculous hard to do you know
imagine I got along I got on a Chelsea
Handler you know me I got a jump suit
made out of Chelsea Handler's skin
scales and I'm gonna defend the do the
second I walk out into the mainstream
with that pop pop somebody gonna you
know put me in that hard scarf baby and
choke me out so the fact that Davy
Crockett did that highly unrecognized as
a hero highly unrecognized what am I
gonna tell you I'll be in Nashville this
weekend if you're in Nashville come out
and show some love I think it's already
sold out but I don't I do think it is
I'll be at Zanies other cities that I'm
coming to I'm just gonna name the cities
I do this fast
Toronto Charlotte Appleton Wisconsin
Phoenix Arizona
Buffalo Salt Lake City and Washington DC
all those places are available right now
Theo von comm slash tour t oh you are
and look if you have thoughts or
anything I'm talking about you know hit
the hotline nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three also if you're
struggling
was something you need thoughts or
suggestions or you think that people can
help maybe you don't have a circle of
friends right now that you think
somebody you know and you feel like
somebody maybe could um you know just
share some insight you know that there's
things that I get scared about sometimes
and I'll talk about them on here and I'm
okay with that and so if you feel like
you have something like that then you
can call too and and we can be that
voice for each other and we can propose
that out to to some of the people out
there and see what they think to see if
we can you know do a little bit of
crowdsource for helping out you know
crowdsource because we all need a little
bit of help sometimes let's take some
calls man we got a call right here let's
see what happened the oh what up dude
Alex what's up Alex
short for alexandr or Alexa which is
well know Alexa's newer so that was your
name before that because you sound older
than that Alex go more Alex like acts
like acts a little bit like acts but
with two other letters in it home word
last name huh I can't with me and my
boys came to your show and Riley about a
month ago I've been caught up in that
work life dude ain't had time to call
you and work like baby no worries man I
appreciate you working man working hard
that's good for you
homeward leave you a message I just
wanted to tell you I was sorry for
trying to steal your championship belt
dude I got caught up in the moment man
when we were beat you and I was super
hyper and we were all just yelling and
screaming and carrying on and and I
remember that I remember there being
over there in Raleigh and somebody
trying to slip off with daddy's [ __ ]
fine waste piece you know with that
little Fort Knox that I rocks above
macaques you know that TF ATK
championship strap and I'll tell you who
don't have that thing Chris Delia's
don't have it he's rich and he can buy
anything he wants in the world you know
he can buy a you know a crystal
parachute or whatever he wants he can
buy different types of
dishware [ __ ] he could eat out he
could buy somebody's hands and [ __ ]
you know Aqua Net I'm really hard into
it just a pair of hands and he could eat
soup out of those if he wants out of
human hand bowls but he can have that
strap baby because the people voted son
and he don't have that mother I so
that's my piece that keeps me going and
I'm sorry if you got caught up in the
moment tried to go off with a man I
accept your apology let's hear a little
more I just I got wrapped up dude try to
walk off with your felt man oh the magic
is real brother and you got those David
Copperfield boy you got that Siegfried
and Roy you got that Tiger crawling all
up in your [ __ ] neck in your neck
nuts do cuz I feel like in our brain we
have this you know we have this thing
that sensory space and that's your neck
nuts and boy they get you flamed up just
like anything to make your brain erect
with excitement and adventure and joy
and everything and I like that that's
what happened to you guys out there I'm
glad you called me
now all my buddies are calling me felt
jack but I appreciate that and belt Jack
actually is a perverse term dude we had
to do by us growing up and this dude um
you know he had pants right and the
pants he would cut out the back of his
kind of the back of his pants and pushes
he had a long pretty long wiener I'll be
honest with you and I didn't see I think
as a child I probably saw you know from
the up and up I saw maybe 12 wieners
three adult nine youth and and this boy
had a damn I mean this thing looked like
it could write a note I mean it was a
hit home way you know I'm saying this
thing look like if he didn't keep tabs I
wanna do what's going on plug in you
know go read a book or something if you
didn't keep it busy like this thing
looked like it needed like you
needed school supplies and it also
needed school supplies but what this
dude would do man he had this weird
fetish where he would I don't know
photos I guess there's a fetish you can
have a fetish as a child you just don't
realize it but he would kind of put a
little hole out in the back of his pants
and push his wiener out through the back
of his pants so if you looked at him
from behind it look I get a little bit
of a tail you know and it looked like he
had a kind of a soft kind of pink tail
and that was actually front wiener and
he just kind of pulled it out through
the back of his pants and and people
would call I don't know if they called
him belt jack but isn't that his his
name was Jackson and people would call
him Jack but you made me think of that
when you said belt jack but thanks for
calling man I appreciate that I
appreciate you calling about that we all
want to do a follow-up we had a young
man that called in last week hey soos
and he called it about quitting his job
and here is a moment of that call I'm on
my way into work job I [ __ ] hate a
good job listing job he he spilled vice
for the family but I hate it kind of
something so great and hey Suz hated his
job and his two-hour commute to work and
you know I was trying to think about
suggestions for this and all I had was
just don't you know don't quit your job
yet until you have another plan you know
you want to have another plan but I
wanted to get some some of our listeners
thoughts and a lot of listeners hit the
hotline with suggestions for his ooze
you know we try to offer suggestions
instead of you know direct advice
because suggestions people are more
likely to take them but here we go man
right here this is a call that came in
for hey-zeus and I'm just playing the
middleman here hey Zeus here you go new
Toronto Canada dude and I'm coming up
there this month if I can get into kanae
can Anna - dude I can an in a blank it
what is it do the North Pole bro what
y'all doing it up there huh
y'all up there hiding snow up in each
other
you know packing each other's boots with
dirty snow or something if they're
brushing your hair with [ __ ] you know
up there with those mittens on dude you
got to be wild to put your hand into a
mitten don't you I'll put a glove on
I've been putting a glove on since I was
a child I'll put a glove I found a dirty
glove and put it in there and just let
my brain get infected with you know the
imaginations that live in that little
street hand piece that I just found that
little [ __ ] pavement hitchhiker but I
met mittens are for the rich bro mittens
are for the rich you gonna put your hand
inside of something it's all warm in
there dude that's like a mitten is like
a damn studio apartment for your hand
you don't get in a [ __ ] mitt and then
feel uncomfortable I can't even get I
put my hand in a mint in my hand
wouldn't come out for a month
there was having such a good time in
there am it and what does it even stand
what is mitten mitten Romney what is it
you know a mitten is something a mitten
like oh oh I know what I'll do I'll send
my hand to Barbados and do a mitten you
probably put your hand in a mitten you
pulled it out of comes out with a tan
you know it comes out with you know it
killed its you know it left its wife and
met someone else in the sand it come out
with its hair Alcorn Road up and you
know is dating a brother you know when
uh you know an island brother in Mun
you've got you want to sneak a mitten is
mittens are for the elite ok if you want
me gonna catch me in a mother if I can
glove boy you're gonna catch me out in
the mean [ __ ] digit streets boy then
finger ethos you know with a violencia
still pop song bro pop pop down the
three fingers bro I'm that glove I'm
that glove wearer but anyhow didn't mean
to interrupt you let's go on homeward I
just wanted to follow me
a previous podcast so called indigo done
their job of a super long ride is do I
have three similar situation probably
about four years ago
BP had both two-hour drive did way I'm
[ __ ] Josh you know [ __ ] a garbage
[ __ ] job just [ __ ] bought [ __ ]
[ __ ] worker
dang dude that's a lot of shits and one
thing dude so homework so I kind of
decided to think about things that I
enjoyed my life every hobby that kind of
stuff and put a little time and effort
to you and some research on jobs that
might kind of tickle my fancy little bit
you know might up oh yeah dude I told
you up in Canada dude that they're
tickling each other's fancy that is a
luxury bruh y'all up there living high
on the hog tickling each other's fancy
dude we don't even have fancy bra where
I'm from dude if somebody showed you
their fancy bra dude that was that
wasn't gonna end very well man you know
and so a lot of times it's illegal if
there's an adult around I mean this is
unbelievable but let's hear more my
interesting they enjoy what I do so I
decided to go to school part-time laws
don't work in my good job you I'm a
fireman and I found that human jobs that
you got to give that community and help
other people are really being so good
down by man I love this you know I love
hearing this actually right here this is
making me feel really good man you know
because you say man well you you know
you're attacking this from a couple
different ways you're saying okay you
held your job you get you took a
part-time you took on part-time
learnings you could become a fireman and
that's something that your kids are
gonna admire there's somebody that said
marvel by everybody its service-oriented
you help
fighting fire do you think of what fire
does whatever it wants to
that's what fire does bro water you
could do some stuff with water aquarium
block it off keep a little water at the
house if you want be like that you know
couple water bowl of water
you know waterfall water can't hold it
up can't keep its act together waterfall
you know drain water drains out of
something water just leaves the earth
and goes you know into the center of the
universe but fire fires that frenetic
[ __ ] you know it's that frisky risky
[ __ ] hot STD you know it's Mother
Nature's um that's that mother you know
that's that you know 700 degree mother
nature's menstrual cycle
that's just roving across the land
cooking buildings dude everybody's a
kielbasa turd a hole that's fire let's
hear more brother home word a lot easier
and just tucked on the drive a little
bit it's actually gonna blasting for me
I still got a super long commute into
work though those two hours each way but
it gives me the opportunity to learn a
lot just listening to different mod got
it made you learn a lot more than what I
ever would I be bored I've been twenty
did it work so there's some positives
man look I loved your approach there you
know you got the fireman job you know
you picked it up and you got into that
because it's something you enjoy now you
feel like you're of service you know you
you look at the drive instead of aw [ __ ]
this two-hour commute
dude there's some great look first of
all you can listen to this past weekend
you can listen other great podcasts you
know you can listen to you know there's
a lot of educational things out there
there's a lot of murder mysteries and
heat this man did it in Canada also
first of all let's be honest in Canada
it's a two-hour commute to get to your
mailbox they got so much land in Canada
and I think if Canada really was being
generous they donate a little bit of
land to some places you know maybe um
the Gaza Strip these people over there
these [ __ ] over there fighting
over a sidewalk G up bruh
somebody should donate some land to
these [ __ ] goons over there gunning
each other up for a bunch of [ __ ]
sidewalk man G up bruh somebody needs to
help these cats out but uh but thank you
for the call that's a good suggestion
you know use the time get some part-time
work use the the commute as a blessing a
lot of that is perspective and finding
your own motivation you know find that
in you what do you do you want to do
something different than you you know
it's gonna be how that fight or flight
it's not in us as much anymore so you
can use podcast for motivation fighting
fire that sounds like a motivator that's
actually you might relight your own
pilot light inside of you and that's
beautiful man I appreciate that call
let's take another suggestion here for
hey-zeus homework my name is sue and I'm
from Austin dang that's that hey Zeus oh
hey Zeus I said Jesus connection right
there this is cool man you know I feel
like I'm water right now and y'all just
walking on me to meet each other this is
beautiful you know and I also want to
say that's just what we're listening to
this if you're a listener you can see
it's hard to hear some of these calls
guys if you are gonna hit the hotline
and I'm not shaming you for the call
that you did make or the calls that
we're gonna get back to but just do a
regular call you notice man obviously
something's going on in the background
it could be you know something he might
be at an art show or that you know he's
doing construction work or looking for
gold or whatever they got a backhoe
rolling in the background or you know if
somebody's trying to you know somebody
with Tourette's is trying to learn the
alphabet who knows but you could hear a
lot of noise in the background you can
eliminate that by just making a direct
call not using you know just call an
actual phone onward
mentioned some things I haven't like a
huge two-hour commute book is ridiculous
first of all he's got to look on the
positive man but he does have a family
that he's supporting and whatnot you
know and aside from that as far as job I
mean try to look for something closer
you know or I mean one of the one of the
biggest things I could probably suggest
is I don't know this guy's situation but
you maybe you ever considered joining
the military so he kind of gets like a
fresh start clean slate and then the our
family's taken care of that way you know
aside from that maybe get a CDL drive
trucks around there's always there's
always driving truck are driving jobs
within the vicinity of anywhere you
anywhere you live doesn't matter where
you know and you can so it use you some
a small time Arizona you can probably
get use at Cpl you get a closer job with
like a twenty two hours now there you go
there's just some suggestions there you
know just some suggestions you know but
I thought that's nice man you can tell
him this man's voice City cares that he
cares you know hey-zeus helping hey-zeus
and that he just cares you could tell he
cares like all one hey-zeus to you know
to feel better about his lot in in life
in his situation right now you know so
find some moments to find some gratitude
and how you can do that is just you know
take a moment some deep breath in the
morning and actually are sip in your car
before you start it in the morning by
yourself for a few minutes and be you
know and just be thankful you know just
be thankful you have a family man that's
so beautiful dude I'd love to have a
family one day you know and I get scared
sometimes thinking about have a family
cuz I don't want to you know I get
scared I don't know something inside of
me you know I mean I know I get into
this sometimes about it you know I don't
want to fail my children you know and I
don't want to fail a wife if I have one
and you know that [ __ ] hits me in the
heart man when I think about that kind
of stuff you know there's a deep fear
that's hidden inside of me like a
Punxsutawney Phil that rarely comes up
and rarely and every time it does it
feel like it sees some shadow that I
never even
I didn't even you know I'm just trying
to cast some light on it and it sees its
shadow every time but so you guys saying
you know you have a beautiful thing here
you got a family man I'll think about
that I think about you know coming home
and having like a little daughter that
runs up to me and loves me you know you
know that makes me feel good you know
you know I was talking to my brother
this weekend was my brother's birthday
and uh and I didn't go home for it I
thought about it you know my mom is
moving out to Arizona again and so
there's gonna be the last time I was
gonna get to see everybody together but
I was just too tired man I've just been
I've honestly been tired you know I've
been tired but uh but it was just nice
man you know like to you know my brother
loves children he loves thinking about
you know like what he you know we're
thinking about what it felt like for him
as a child and what it's like for him as
an adult now and how you know how he can
learn to try to make it life a better
situation for his kids not only make it
better but also you know just learn how
to parent and he really he loves being a
parent he did it's almost a wild man I
think he loves it because he felt like
we didn't have it you know and I talked
about this kind of stuff a lot but I
know it's really important because the
way that we cut off problems in the
world is by cutting him off you know the
way that like you know one thing that
gets my heart sometimes is uh is my
brother like you know he um you know he
looks at pictures of himself from being
a child and he's he didn't have any
emotion and he in any of the pictures
and it always hurts his feelings
sometimes you know that at that point in
his life
nobody was fostering emotions in him or
you know we're asking him how he was
feeling so he wasn't expressing any
feelings and so you know and and that
kind of stuff carries on into your life
and you know carries on into your
adolescence and can affect your
self-worth and how you and you know how
you stand up for yourself in all kinds
of stuff if you don't know how to feel
then then when you do have a feeling
it's gonna be like a tidal wave coming
through a stream and you won't know how
to manage it a lot of times and so my
brother is very active now and thinking
about feelings and stuff like that and
in in just making sure that his children
you know or you know we're just or he's
he's active and cutting off whatever it
was and there's no blunt you know
there's not a lot of blame in it anymore
we're adults but cutting off whatever
happened to him whatever made him his
struggles making it so it doesn't go
into that next generation just that's
how we eradicate kind of stuff in the
world I think but uh but anyway I
appreciate that suggest let's get one
more for hey-zeus here we go hey Zeus
another caller came in hey oh boy cooter
over here Knight ogen what's up cooter
in Idaho dude whoo and that reminds me
actually I made love to a girl one time
over in Boise and I think she was Korean
maybe or who knows man you know my just
died her hair and you know been kind of
uh you know I've been hanging out in
haunted houses or something who knows
but um but anyway thank you for calling
homeward calling the give advice that
guy says he hates his job and whatnot I
don't know what he does he didn't say
what like what his actual job is yeah it
sounds like he just kind of drives two
hours and then just drives home you know
it sounds like really he's somebody that
could be just lost but and that's just a
joke hey Zeus homework I was in the same
boat at one point about four years ago
in my life I was working for a french
fries Factory
that french fry dude it's the best thing
about this podcast the people that I get
to meet man verbally meet audibly you
know that audible acquaintance man this
dude worked at a french fry factory dude
I'd fill my mouth so fast boy you could
catch me and they're [ __ ] out back at
that Tater Tot ChopShop game you won
bruh
if tater tots made suppositories dog can
hey I'll take a couple of russets in my
gusset you know what I'm saying boy
he worked out a french fry factory you
don't even know that french fries were
made somewhere cuz in my mind dude I
think that this is how a french fry
comes into the world
so God you know wakes up in the morning
and he goes into you know like a god
room and they got a potato in their bra
and he holds the potato out into the
world like this and the potato falls
through his fingers bruh in beautiful
little you know cuz your fingers really
if you hold him a certain angle directly
like styled up they make perfect shape
or fries could be come out of and God's
hand can be sharp or soft if he wants it
to be or whatever lavender so God makes
his hand as sharp as possible and that
potato just falls away and all those
little fries just fry down into the
world and land in our mouths dude and if
we want they tought up a little into our
you know our freaking you know that tank
tank bruh you know and then that old
tank tank dude but they man let's hear
more brother onward I'll make it super
good money I hated it though and I ended
up I got a family and I got a wife and a
kid and everything I ended up but I had
to leave and and I joined the trade I
became a plumber you know and I thought
I would hate it but I needed to do
something different and something that
has a skill involved maybe that's about
how you go I went from you know making
almost 19 20 dollars an hour all the way
down to 10 11 dollars an hour so it's a
huge pay cut but now I'm you know fourth
year of a journeyman and whatnot about
to be anyway and I'm making better money
than I was you know so it's just you got
a rebuild based on what the guy did
before but you definitely just got to
rebuild and like you say put one foot in
front of the other and start moving you
know a me man thanks for the call
yeah yes
there's some great suggestions hey Zeus
and I hope you know any of that helps
you but oh Paul so that you know just
that people care you know and that
you're not out here by yourself just
thinking about your own problems that we
do live in a world where there are
caring people that want to offer
suggestions and you know it's hard to
take suggestions you know and I find
that trouble in myself a lot of times
you know but recently and more often in
my life I realize that even though I
want to do everything myself that I need
help you know that I need help
and and it's crazy because I feel being
able to ask for help is one of the
bravest things you can do you know
sometimes for people that have a
depression and struggle with you know
you know abandonment issues and stuff
like that or those sorts of things
having asking for help asking someone
else for help when whatever it was
inside of you someone else is not
offering help at one point in your life
as a youth or whatever is a baby or
whatever that's what made you feel so
empty now having to turn that around and
now ask for that that's the most just so
there's so much vulnerability in that
I'm learning in my own life but also so
empowering and and to realize that
people will help you you know and and
sometimes and I just say that because
you know I don't want to ask for help
because I don't want to take suggestion
but more and more in my life I find
myself look for somebody that has
whatever you want and that want can be a
happiness it can be a comfortability it
can be employment it can be experience
and ask them hey you know I want that
will you help me and the crazy thing is
dude I find more often than not that
people want to help others with whatever
they've learned they want to pass it on
I really really do thanks for the
suggestions for hey-zeus man if you're
thinking about you know getting a new
job or or you know quitting the job that
you have or something like that you're
having to drive long distances to work
or you know you're just lost whatever
now there's some
in that little universe what else oh
we're talking about the fire department
earlier I want to tell you about our
small business we support a small
business and you know we try to support
small business each episode and have an
advertisement and one of those is a
Bixby coffee and Bixby cuff it that's
what I'm drinking right here there's a
magical cup of straight-up that Java
juice juice dude they're [ __ ] oh that
gogo drip drop and this is uh this is
it's great coffee man you know I made
coffee at home because you know to me
getting that you know you get that that
fancy cup out there you paying $6 a cup
you know you got a part that's two
dollars two part next team you know you
nine dollars in and you don't even
[ __ ] know how you know you don't even
know how your day is going you down nine
bucks you out there two-star bucking
just lurking with that [ __ ] up up
that cup of brown upper upper but that
can all change now because you can you
can make Bixby coffee at home its
high-end at specialty stuff but it's
more affordable than grocery store
coffee they do whole bean none of this
half being or this quarter being you
know this is Alma this is this is light
brown cocaine baby that's that less that
Bixby and they make Keurig pods and then
make Nespresso pods but they also got
that bean bean where you could drill it
up and French press it at the house if
you want to show the kids how to put in
some work you know but these are good
stuff man
these are good stuff it's better coffee
at a better price delivered right to
your door to no-brainer go to Bixby
coffee b IX b YC o FF ee comm you can
order right there you can order in your
smartphone it's big speak coffee comm
enter promo code Theo at checkout and
you'll get two weeks of coffee for five
bucks so try it out if you like it keep
trying it out and if you don't then stop
trying it out Bixby coffee comm promote
Theo let's take some of the calls that
came in the hotline as always is nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three man I you know in a person out of
I'm starting to feel a little bit better
man I honestly the last couple weeks
that has been going through me I've been
going through a lot
you know with career change in some and
you know it's scary when people come out
to the shows you know I'm struggling
with smoking cigarettes and not wanting
to and uh and you know just visit my
physical I hadn't been taking care of
myself I've been taking care of myself
running and taking care of myself being
hopeful you know I just have been taken
care they go to care of myself
but I'm grateful that I have this you
know today to do because this gave me
something to look forward to and and I'm
just happy to be here with you guys I'm
sorry to talk about myself so much but I
appreciate it footballs bag dude my
fantasy team sucks but we got that tpw
fantasy football league as well so I
want to thank the teams for joining that
my team is down right now but we still
got a shot I got a couple of Monday
night ballers let's take a call here
here we go
hey deal what's going on man James
fanatic
what's up Cincinnati dude and I saw do
one time he had just picked up a couple
of Milkshakes you know and he you know
he was kind of being wild and these
black girls was fighting and uh and they
saw him with these milkshakes and he was
trying to run from him and his pants
fell down to his ankles cuz he was kind
of you know he was do you know he was
fat but he was also doing some coat so
he was you know that's when your pants
don't know what to do and so his pants
fell down to his ankles and these these
girls beat his ass boy you know these a
couple of moth birds out there you know
these um you know it just like some real
you know some some you know these a
couple Twisted Sisters out there whooped
his ass out there and he we got all beat
up and got milkshake all over him and
then they they are you know they even
finished off one of his shakes and he
only had had about half a couple of he
was trying to save that last shake it
was like double dare you never do you
know like a physical challenge on that
show double dare but why you getting you
ass beat by a couple sisters and they
beat two and a half milkshakes out of
that dude now why that dude had three
milkshakes I think it's hard to do
cocaine and dairy at the same time
but this man lives in a different
universe than I but just you know I
guess it won't that be a crazy game show
if you got three milkshakes and they got
three bad bet just coming up about to
whoop yo ass
how much milkshake can you hold on to
and maybe that could be something we
could do in the future right now we're
focusing on the single mom thing and
we're about to do that game show in the
hotel room but anyway
onward thank you for calling sir my
comment about your episode from Monday
about you know when you change his name
from like you said a little boy's name
to a man's name oh yeah we had a guy
last week got called up he's about to
start a chicken wing establishment and
you know he wanted to think you know if
he's his name I think was Tommy and he
wants to change it you know should he go
to Tom now that he's getting into the
you know that bird arm business let's
hear it more I just just speaking from
my experience you know I've got a
brother who all the family you know we
all call him Jimmy but you know his
peers and his colleagues at work they
call it Tim you know it's uh I feel like
it you just kind of got to feel it out
and then you know all your professional
like I said your peers and colleagues
maybe go with with your man name and you
know your family's always going to call
you by by your little boy named you know
like I said all of our family cost my
brother Timmy and you know I got a
cousin you know same thing all the
family called him Scotty and you know
all this professional peers and
colleagues calling Scott so there you go
that's some option maybe you keep you
know Tim at work you know you attendant
work but you at Timmy at home you know
and I appreciate that call thank you
very much I think though they had this
dude NetBIOS name baby Samuel and this
man was [ __ ] 44 you know 44 45 you
know and he was always drinking on the
problem is he never grew out of that
[ __ ] you know you'd see him over there
[ __ ] gumming down a can of Similac or
[ __ ] drink
of a baby bottle because somebody always
called him baby Samuel and he would do
dice and [ __ ] bet on how many if a
dog was giving birth he'd be out there
betting on how many puppies was gonna
come out of it you know he was that bad
boy I think he's from Bogalusa Louisiana
and dude he couldn't even I mean I don't
know if he could barely even walk dude
you know I don't even think anybody just
he wasn't handicapped nobody taught him
how to walk so baby Samuel we just you
know you'd see him [ __ ] is barely
kind of dragging himself around getting
that who knows is probably gin and
[ __ ] lactate out of a [ __ ] you
know that baby supper that little
[ __ ] infant Cup Cup and that's baby
salmon like here's the thing if you
start calling him Sam maybe he goes to
school and gets his [ __ ] together but if
you always calling him baby Samuel you
know I'm saying then he probably gonna
probably you know piss his pants till he
probably 60 or 70 and he going to cash
out because you know everybody's taking
care of and then that's gonna be his
life you know maybe that's what we're
making sometimes and you know you know
with helping everyone and we're making
baby Samuels maybe he learns to walk if
he has to walk but if he always can just
you know ride around with that that diet
or that baby diaper arm you know in a
diaper that's just regular pants that
you could [ __ ] in look I think it's a
great invention but a baby might walk
sooner if it had to get up and wash this
ass off as all I'm saying thank you for
that call though let's take one more
call and this was another response to
last week's calls about when do you
change your name to a adult name you
know if you are uh you know Danny when
do you go to Dan you know if you're
Richard when do you go to dick never
that's when let's hear more anyone
appeals to our hero in a Oklahoma
Oklahoma boy thank you for calling man
what just happened in Oklahoma something
I was reading the other day damn it look
fun too oh they called exact Joe exotic
out there exotic
Joe and he was running them bait you
know he you know he hired somebody that
you know he was you know selling large
cats and he hired somebody else to
[ __ ] get him out the cat game you
know he was trying to kill another cat
you know another business meow you know
so let's hear more I'm calling in on the
name change I think that let your
buddies do that for you I went from
being called Tyler to being called ty to
being called P and then I had a nickname
me that for me Billy I don't know why
they call me Philly but and Philly is a
baby horse and you know I'll tell you
one animal that don't get as much credit
as it should is a baby horse cuz think
about the when you're a baby horse man
people expect so much out of you you
gotta maybe they want you to race maybe
didn't want you to you know grow your
hair long and beautiful and then sell it
to put it on the internet and people
sell it in India you know when you were
a horse they there's just so much in a
baby horse at that because most of a lot
of times sorry emails open a lot of
times when you see stuff happen and uh
it for adult horses they get all the
love but baby horses are out there as
well you know and you can sometimes if
you put your ear up to the [ __ ]
universe at night you can hear I'm
asking for help but that's another
suggestion right there let your friends
decide let's hear a little more we do I
think they say I look Filipino but I'm
not and then now that you got shortened
to Phil okay so Philly then the Filipino
and then now you're Phil Wow and you
started off at Randall damn dude you
[ __ ] look man we trying to send this
dude into schizophrenia
you know we trying to keep him tightened
up so it sound like you took one name
and went on a nine name but I want you
to tone it down give somebody else a
name you got there got nine names you
probably run around with fake IDs and
all of this [ __ ]
come on bro get one name dude you know
we can't give this guy some crazy advice
next next thing you know he's out there
you know just calling himself just rag
baby or something you know next thing
you know he gives himself a name it
doesn't fit him and he's selling crack
let's hear another call that came in
thank you so much Maui just want to tell
you you know that don't worry about so
many people listening or don't let that
change the way you do that you know I
really personally I love hearing you
working out your feelings in present
time it's super raw and organic and it's
cool because I can totally like feel
myself in my feelings
coming out at the same time does that
make sense so it's like really cathartic
to listen to you and so yeah I'm just
saying just be you and and do you and
don't worry about whatever how its
sounding or anything
thanks for us I appreciate that that's
nice you to say that yeah I think yeah
I've been going through some of that
kind of stuff you know it's like when
things get you know when they get busier
not to let him feel busier you know what
I think all my life I've felt like you
know I've had that chip on my shoulder
kind of that underdog kind of thing that
you know that nut sack in my neck that
Marshall Mathers kind of and now you
know I just don't want to ever not it's
like the only thing I've known is how to
be an underdog you know the only thing
I've kind of known is like that people
didn't think I could do something and so
when you start to like people start to
acknowledge that you're doing something
you know what I'm just talking about in
my work in comedy you know it's
different you know
because you're like hi you know in a
weird way it's like ah you know those
were always the people the people that
you know look like they knew what they
were doing or the people who like the
people that like I always know that's
not I never I always wanted it to look
II I just have all that's the that's the
skin I wear the best that's the skin I
know myself in is the skin of watch I
can do this you know are you gonna look
at me like I can't do this you don't
think I can be where I'm from and do
this you don't think I can get out here
in the Hollywood and show these
[ __ ] what's up you know you
don't think you know where I'm from you
know we didn't have this and we didn't
have that are you gonna make fun of this
and when I was a kid are you gonna make
fun of me for this you can make fun of
it for this I'll [ __ ] show you you
know and it's tough to get some rid of
some of that and I don't want to get rid
of it but it's tough too because you
can't go into like meetings you know
she's like you know it's like it's weird
because it every if an art at a certain
point an art or a drive if it starts to
become you know you prove yourself if
you start to show the proof and people
see the proof then it becomes you know
more you're not you're not hidden
anymore you're not like you you don't
you have to protect you
hmm kind of think and feel that I'm
trying to talk and feel at the same time
you don't you all like them one of the
main things that I had was that odd I
knew that I was capable and I felt like
other people didn't know
or I believed that I was and now when
you show up and people know that you are
it kind of makes me a little upset
because that that knowledge that I could
do this job you know that knowledge my
whole life that I knew that I was able
to do something or achieve a goal for me
that other people might dropped in my
neighborhood or look at me
you know look at my clothes or look at
like you know you know or see me walking
home from school or you know see my
family or see you know like see where I
lived or something like that and say oh
you know he'll he that boy he'll never
do that
you know he'll never man it's gonna be
you know rough for him or that you know
whatever or he you know man I feel sorry
for that kid or whatever you know
whatever even if those things weren't
real and I just thought him in my head
you know like like the fact that I knew
I could do something is what made me
feel it was the only thing that I knew
that they didn't know it was one thing
that I had that they didn't that nobody
else that nobody else had like other
people I might see other people that had
you know their families had more money
and stuff like that or they had you know
both their parents or you know their mom
didn't have to like you know delived you
do like a man's job or do delivery work
or you know or uh you know them and
their siblings got along and love each
other well I don't know what whatever
you know they didn't wet the bed every
night or whatever whatever it was you
know but the fact that I knew I could do
something that my drive was all like
yeah that I just once other people know
it's like the only thing I had was that
I knew that I could
that I had that I was that I was going
to be that I would do something and so
now it's wilder because it's like you
show up at the comedy clubs and people
are there it is great you know it's
great I love it look I'm grateful but it
takes it you know it's it's like how do
I stay in my space but also not staying
it in an angry place because it's
different when you now other people know
oh this guy's gonna put on a show I've
heard about him you know and I'm not
trying to say that in a braggy way I'm
just saying when I look at some of the
facts like you know the places are
selling out you know when people are
coming out to support and I'm grateful
but it's definitely been a learning
experience and an emotional learning
experience you know letting go the fact
that uh not letting go but just I know
you know it's hard to just let go the
only thing that I had sometimes and I
guess I don't have to let go of it but
it's just that's kind of it's just
interesting to kind of feel that out
what is that you know what's going on
now how do I feel now what's going on
how do I still be Who I am
how do I not self-sabotage stuff just to
keep myself in that place of other
people doubting me you know but I
appreciate that call and I was very
sweet of you and Hawaii's a beautiful
place and thank you for calling Lissa
let's take a call right here here we go
hey what up feel this bubble all the way
from Kailua Hawaii men the dude ask you
about things you like to do in it when
you were a kid
Oh Paulo thanks for calling man from
Hawaii is another Hawaii call I had no
idea homeward well it made me it made me
remember my childhood I grew up in uh on
the south side of the hemisphere damn
dog a [ __ ] a space baby huh dang you
sound like eat maybe Ilan must little
stepchild south side of the hemisphere
of what in his aim
you and when we were growing up well we
used to do a whole lot we used to be
into like [ __ ] like fighting fish
fighting fish how bruh homeward you know
ah man I remember is to have a fighting
fish and badass fish man we heard about
this guy this old man there's to have
all this [ __ ] fighting fish like a
fighting fish like what like James Jay
Barracuda dude like what onward and
here's the view yeah also be a legend in
the town when it comes to fighting fish
and uh anyways we went looking for that
guy and turned out that we walked off
damn we got beef in these fish streets
like about an hour and a half and I had
no idea was anyways I was about seven
years old uh but we found the guy and
man this picture the guy is [ __ ]
super right sorry skinned big-ass nose
and big-ass pores all over his face
[ __ ] I remember to this day man rings
on his finger his house had no door no
electricity but he had all this fighting
fish on shelves all over the house Jesus
man so this guide has had a helpful a
house full of fighting fish burn you
guys went over there what is he going on
and anyway I brought my fish over there
to fight the guy [ __ ] bro this thing is
like damn bro it's like finding Nemo
he's rocky man this [ __ ] is getting
intense let's hear more and I remember
my friend bet some amount of money with
the guys the my fish would be his fish
and any way we want
and the guy [ __ ] made us run with a
[ __ ] big ass a machete of the size of
his arm so yeah we were in running uh
[ __ ]
whatever I'm on my team I spend that on
my fish and [ __ ] left my fish over
there - damn bruh dude I yes oh you
caught up in them then fly weight fish
streets man dang dude that's intense
brah that's that who you know you out
there in them you know in them UFC unagi
streets and then Makemake you out there
you got a tuna and a carp going
toe-to-toe brah
you got their fight and fish dude and
Hawaii you said you brought your fish
over to his house I just picture like
some kid just carrying his [ __ ] fish
in a bowl over there yeah I'm here I
heard your seahorse has been talking
[ __ ] wow that's crazy man I didn't know
as you've Riegel out there and Hawaii
brah you guys out there [ __ ] just
going toe-to-toe
that's that Mac rule that you know you
got there smack in the you know smack
and mackerel against each other
dang man but look just stay straight to
stay safe out there
you know carp a carp brah get it done
man good luck out there dude thank you
for calling in man all right let's see
your let's take another call here so
Theo just callin replies because you're
wondering who's listening out here to
your podcast man it's a circle calls
from Tucson your old home - son baby boy
out there brah used to watch Mexican
kids fist fight each other in abandoned
car washes out there my mom you know
live out an East she's moving back out
there out off a Golf Links dude
I shot out - Pema City brah shout out to
them Wildcats boy bear down Tucson
Arizona dude a bunch of like empty River
Basins brah they keep saying there's
water and there's no water then one day
that [ __ ] comes like the Bible like
somebody just cracked open a big huge
Bible up on a mountaintop and there's
water just runs down that hole
everything enough water for a year they
got cactuses out there
you know you hit a back alley a couple
dudes a couple of brothers out there a
couple of Mexican brothers maybe even in
[ __ ] one white dude a couple [ __ ]
you know low-key closet and Mac Miller
types out there grilling up some [ __ ]
scorpion you know you catch a [ __ ]
jaw full of scorpion meat a couple of
you know a little head of peon get that
jaw full of pee on you out there [ __ ]
people cutting the tops of their cars
off no shirt sleeves you'll see a do
that Bank of America brought a manager
suit no sleeves on that [ __ ]
that's Tucson bro a lot of people out
there knows a lot of dream catchers bro
a lot of people out there caught up dude
Air Force Davis mom Pam and people out
there slinging [ __ ] big school Big
Gulp a lot of big gulps and dream
catchers bro you got that sip sip and
you got that [ __ ] that dormir say
hitter that dormir say [ __ ] dream
cage that dream catcher onward I just
wanted to say what's up hope you're
doing well working in the graveyard
security she's doing all right man oh
nice we want to know who's listening the
show we got a graveyard security worker
dude wow I never thought people boo be
breaking into a graveyard mmm and but
now that I think about it though in our
town had a graveyard and people would
break in there and steal bones and stuff
out of there I thought it was always for
soup and stuff when I was a child but
now as I'm realizing as I'm older
probably for say onsen doing say on
Surrey mm-hmm more smoke the Jets ready
to get out of here um taking it easy man
being positive good vibe tribe all the
time a good vibe tribe I like that man
let's hear more thanks for everything
you do keep making us happy land being
positive even when you're down we got
your back just like you got ours love
you man hey gang brah gang dude I
appreciate that and man you're a pioneer
out there you getting high working at
the graveyard man dude you sound like
wow you sound like Tim Burton's a little
side
kick out there man that's brave as hell
dude I won't even be in a graveyard at
night and you working the night shift at
that with the dead and you're getting
high
dude are you asking for ghosts come bro
I would lose my mind you got to put that
on camera right you need to start you
know they got that Paul flirt guy that
guy that was flirting at the front desk
at a medical billing place dude you you
got to start hiding the Cameron just
getting scared brah dude being in a
graveyard who first of all who's coming
to get all it again
these people are dead it's sad that
that's the world we live in you know
that there's probably a beginner thieves
out there who don't want to try and
robber or a living person yet so they're
gonna get out there and try to [ __ ]
put the jack jack on the deceased
unbelievable but that's that's where we
live now man that's where we live dude
you know but amen to you man you out
there keeping somebody's holding the
dead down cuz you know what's crazy is
Latino culture those people they try and
remember they're dead you know they got
that el Dia de los Muertos and we had
Halloween when I was growing up you know
you didn't really think about the dead
but you'd run around and [ __ ] catch a
snicker from the neighbor bruh I'll
catch a [ __ ] jaw full of snicker and
go home and just you know masturbate or
something or if I couldn't you know if I
wasn't old enough to masturbate I just
put a bunch of [ __ ] sugar in my mouth
and pass out you know but damn and you
out there and a mean spirit streets what
was that dude when you're high
everything you [ __ ] there's ghosts
everywhere
you out there making ghosts dude man you
are a come on bro
you're like the Anthony Bourdain you out
there just [ __ ] just sniffing around
them spirits bro you ever trying to
[ __ ] go stop that but you have I
could see that dude if I got high enough
broad be out there dude I'd be out there
again you know catching a little bit of
that ex
doggystyle or something you got to be
out there dude you out there man I can't
even imagine that being in a graveyard
all night and smoking pot what the [ __ ]
hey man though dude I love your attitude
that good vibe tribe dude all day I
appreciate that man
I appreciate you calling in let's take
one more call man we got another one
right here here we go hey what's up
video I'm calling them from Oregon man
I'm just listening to your latest
episode and now you're talking a little
bit about the dark guards about that
self-love and I've heard you talk about
it in the past and you haven't really
mentioned as much in the past the
connection with the Parana goofy and
yeah I was just wondering if if you
differentiate at all you know the self
love when when the pornography is
involved versus you know just self love
when you're using your own imagination
are you trying to be trying to avoid
both of them or are you just trying to
avoid the the pornography these are some
things that I've struggled with in the
past and you know I I found lately that
you know just avoiding the the
pornography and and still could just
kind of learning how to love myself
without having to involve those those
parts with the dark arts amen brother
yeah that pornography it's like somebody
took your imagination and said hey I can
make I can do better than your
imagination and I fell for the trap
that's really what happened I mean I
used to look my imagination whine I
would imagine all kind of stuff you know
we raid an Indian village and the
suddenly they you know I'm supposed to
be like one of the Raiders and we're
coming in and you know they fighting
people and grilling people up and
everything and stealing fruits and
catching a little bit of you know
stealing you know they got exotic meats
and their snake meat everything but then
as I'm riding by my horse and swinging
my sword I see this bad little knot
v9 t VAR ETA you know this little
Mexican native girl a nutty vow Tita and
I so I slip off of uh you know my horse
and I write a small horse a lot of men
out there on these big horses yeah well
it's easy to [ __ ] hit somebody with a
sword when you're on a big horse dude
because you I think that's cheating bro
I've been down there on a little pony
and I be the only warrior coming in on
the in the tribe that's on a pony and
I'm like oh man and the ladies can see
me better because I'm closer to the
ground because a lot of the ladies in
some of these places that were pillaging
these small ladies and one of them I
sketch her I threw a little you know not
a window but something like that you
know something with the windows kind of
missing there's because there never was
a window cuz it enough glass in this
village they never had glass but if they
did have glass somebody were to throw in
a lawnmower through it so I catch the
eye this bad little naughty vow to eat
die and next thing you know I'm off my
horse and she and I are just [ __ ]
licking the inside of each other's faces
boy just playing taste test with the
back of each other's throats dude and
just thinking about how bad we can be
and just wanting to put bad but cute
sauce all over each other's bodies and
yeah that was my imagination man so next
thing you know I'm [ __ ] wearing you
know I'm doing all kind of stuff I'm
gonna I've got a teepee in the back of
my yard and I'm jerking off because my
imagination used to do it for me
but then pornography came through and
said I will will do will do your
imaginations job for you and they do it
but they don't do it with enough sense
enough actual sense where they where
they tempt my senses you know it's just
straight to the visual straight to the
brain straight to the you know Wiener
and straight to the ejaculate but back
in the day you know when I was I could
feel the pony I was riding in on and I
get a little bit you know I'm riding in
on that pony and I'm getting a little
turnt up just even being on his little
back and I can't even feel him fired up
he might even have an erection this
little bitty you know this kind of
strong you know fast Pony I'm on the
fastest [ __ ] Pony they've ever even
had
you know and so he's kind of
wheat-colored because he was raised in
wheat and some of the coloring came off
on his skin
and so he's wheat colored man and you
know we ride in the village and he has a
he's erect boy and people like that
pony's got a big dick on him and we get
in there man and it's but I can feel his
skin and I can feel even his body just
grinding up between my legs I'm Marty
you know my Chi is up and that's
happening in my imagination before I've
even met the lady that's my imagination
making pornography this new [ __ ] is just
you know some you know some thrifty
[ __ ] shows up in some fishnet it
doesn't even look like nice fishnet
literally this [ __ ] looks like I'm not
talking about something off the coast of
Seattle I'm talking about something that
catching you know where that where they
down there catching gar off of Corpus
Christi okay I'm talking about some
[ __ ] you know some [ __ ] you know
some shoddy Nets they using over there
over there are actually probably some
they probably use some real Nets down
there in Corpus Christi up there in
Seattle they probably using these you
know nets that kind of catch fish but
give the fish a chance to get away as
well you know they're probably using you
know strong spider webs that's what
these you know and these these in the
pornography these girls show up they
already at the door you don't even know
why they at the door there's knocking
door-to-door [ __ ] whoever answers
come on so that's the pornography next
thing you know they [ __ ] and people's
holding a butthole is open and
everything and they catching cold they
got a new when I saw a while back it was
uh somebody catching a snowflake in
there but what does that do
who's jerking off to that bra that's
nothing you know that's just whether
that's like you know [ __ ] man that makes
me just wonder you know that's where
people that wear mittens
I'm gloves brah you catch me in gloves
dude I know where each of my fingers are
at ain't taking a chance with this
[ __ ] little hand Barbados they making
come out but I riding on that pony and
then I get off the pony and I feel my
bare feet on the ground
and I see her face the shadow of her and
she's in there and her little you know
in her tea in her Hut she's in like a
hut like a grass hut you know and she
wrote and in the dirt she wrote with a
stick it said come get this coochie she
wrote with that with a stick in the dirt
and that's what I saw like damn this
chick speaks English you know and next
you know I'm in there and we're just you
know just being wild bruh just feeling
each other's mouth of maize you know or
my Azores however you pronounce it and
just being [ __ ] native as we can and
my penis just suddenly it's like erect
and it has ears pierced with pieces of
bone going through the sides of its ears
my penis has ears all of a sudden you
know and I want to just [ __ ] be a
maniac and I just want to just teach her
about my totem pole and she's all
willing bro
she's willing Browne she is she might
have on a shirt but [ __ ] even that she's
never even owned a shirt it's not even a
shirt it's just like somebody else just
like put a little bit of like um you
know some type of you know it's like a
leather or not even leather it's like
maybe you know animal skin probably
marmoset she was like a marmoset
brassiere and it should salt hits and
marm bruh you can just see that [ __ ]
marm skin holding up their top tots
grown she's got asked cheeks that are
the color of a million [ __ ] sunsets
and we make love man and we make love
and there's people in the distance die
and then [ __ ] you know and steel and
you know coffee and corn and some of the
natives have been making cocaine on the
side and somebody [ __ ] cracks into a
bag of that and you know gets a snout
full and runs into a [ __ ] open fire
but that's what I like that was my
pornography this from my imagination
lived and now it's being its killed off
we're killing it off you know it's all
it's like all of our senses it's been
taken over his options now
you don't have to think for yourself you
have to feel for yourself Oh we'll take
care of you you don't have a house we
will give you a halfway house so you
view a quarter way house hey you can
sleep in this dog house what about a
tree house what about a hammock what
about a mobile home lost your home take
a [ __ ] home with you you can't lose
here in America you don't need to have
any feelings to survive for yourself
Oh pornography sure why I think about
what kind of wife think about titties
when you could just see titties brah
take the easy way out see some tits no I
want to think about him I want to think
about tit I used to think about tits
having real milk in him when I was young
you know two percents Kimbra my god
mm-hmm and I should think I used to even
have this vision armor when I was young
of a girl like washing a car with big
old tits but uh just big old TI TTS and
at the very end she would clean the car
completely [ __ ] on bottoms okay I'm not
I'm not gross okay she had on bottoms
I ain't seen somebody's full crotch
while they supposed to be cleaning a car
okay you don't work and have your full
crotch out but she would have you know
she had um and then she would actually
use milk from her breasts to do the to
do the tires and I'll like do though you
know where they clean the tires and put
that tire shine on them like that arm
roll and she had kind of armor all milk
in her breasts and God dang it was
beautiful and that was imagination man
and I'm even erect right now and I don't
know if there's any way a better way to
uh attend an episode you know but
whatever it is man use yourself we have
to get back into ourselves we have to
find our motivation man we have to it's
in us and it will die unless we unless
we cultivate it you know pornography is
just somebody took your imagination like
oh we'll make it for you trust us I'm
good man and that's why I fight it in
yeah there is a difference between you
know watching pornography and you know
pleasuring yourself to that and then
also after a while if you don't pleasure
yourself you feel the desire to pleasure
yourself and that's called natural bust
and if you do that that's natural man
there's nothing wrong with that but when
you become addicted and you're doing it
out of habit from watching masturbation
that's gonna have the problem I've
talked about that before but what else
man that's it dude that's it for today I
think we're good I'm good this is a long
episode I thought this episode's gonna
be in our mouths trying to get out of
here but you know I appreciate it I
appreciate our sponsors we got unruly
bastards bixby coffee and as always that
beard brand bra you want to spice up
your beard get it man that old money sea
salt spray it on flex bro bring the
beach just to your neck bra put a little
[ __ ] a couple squirts of the atlantic
around your crotch or whatever have some
bad babies running around that thing
they trying to look a little they trying
to find a seaport for that poo but we
have to protect our nature of who we are
you know our feelings and our desires
and everything any human nature is
becoming is being out sourced you know
and it's it's okay part of it's just the
times it's what's going on but we have
to recognize it and you have to say okay
I'm not gonna use porn I'm gonna use my
imagination your imagination it's the
original app bro it's the app that God
gave you it's the iPhone your
imagination anything in the world bro
it's Google Maps it's that Google view
or whatever we can go right on the
street view that's your imagination I
can do anything right now in my head you
know I can watch a dragon learn to play
volleyball right now in my head I'm
doing it right now
it's for me we have as and what is there
anymore of amazing ability in the world
than some of those abilities the ones we
have inside of us
the fight or flight the things that
there are things inside of us that our
ways outside of us are going to start
deteriorating from our DNA and we have
to recognize that you know we have to
recognize that with to you know
recognize that we are a bit of a museum
in a way and we have some exhibits that
we want to take care of and we want to
keep you know we want to keep but um
thank you guys so much for the calls
thank you guys for being here so I'm
gonna take us out of here remember
always you can hit the hotline nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three as well if you're struggling with
something you're struggling with some
mental health issues and you don't think
you can get help you can try a service
that I've tried recently it's called
better help calm go to better help calm
slash Theo th EO today and you can find
a therapist you can try on your phone
you can start through text you can do
video chat there's some different
options I've tried the service and I
enjoy it better help calm slash do on
the way out man what better way to get
out of here man then I saw Bishop Gunn
this weekend and and I had a good time
dude it and I man it reminded me of
Aerosmith from Mississippi a beautiful
band and uh and I'm glad I went for a
couple runs I'm looking for another run
tonight I'm gonna keep my blood flowing
and because you have to do that you have
to match you have to match your it's so
much easier for your brain to help
itself if it's got some fresh blood
going in and out of it you know I'm
saying you can't keep you can't you
can't teach uh a stagnant steak new
seasonings you can't teach a stagnant
steak new seasonings nope you got to
keep that flow you keep that flow going
on man you know keep that flow going
Braun it's easy it's so much gonna be so
much easier to add spice it's gonna be
so much easier to add spice to your head
meat be good to yourselves out there
because you deserve it man
you know
a person if you've made any mistakes
that's okay you know I've made a lot and
and uh and we're gonna be okay and if
you're struggling you don't know what to
do man ask for help you know we're down
here with each other and I know it's
hard sometimes I mean you want to be
that big dog you know it's the only
thing you've ever known is taking care
of yourself but but man people really
want to love you I know that and I'm
starting to learn that for myself I love
you I know that man and I'm excited to
see some of you guys I'll see you in
Nashville this weekend I'll see you in
Toronto the weekend after and be good to
yourselves you probably deserve it man
we're making it bro that's all we're
doing
[Music]
I've seen home in about a hundred days I
can almost hear mama please for my
restless soul and now he made $1 night
spell but where it's going ain't you me
and I still get wet I'm bound to go
[Music]
it's a good song this have gun-making it
bacon bath and we'll put the link in
there
thank you guys for sticking with me man
thank you to patreon we're gonna do some
cool stuff together promise
[Music]
if their spiral wasn't our glance I'm
sailing I should've put it down
but how
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
shout-out to everybody that came out to
[Music]
but I'm in good shape man it was fun to
watch them
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I hate seen old mandala Walternate I can
almost hear mama peep from our recipes
[Music]
while me making wrong feel right man you
can help somebody today know that
somehow someway it could be a smile
could be a hug could be a high-five
it could be some suggest suggestion
could be not given advice just listening
you know it could be texting somebody
back but not saying something mean you
know say what you mean but don't say it
mean that's what my brother always told
his children say what you mean but don't
say it mean you know it's funny man here
I'm a 38 year old child still learning
lessons that's life and that's really a
gift isn't it that at 38 years old I'm
still able to learn imagine if you only
got to learn when you were a kid and we
were stuck in and that was it we never
got to crack open any of that again or
learn again mm-hmm
man pretty blessed be good to yourselves
you probably deserve it that was Bishop
gun-making it hit the hotline you know
hit the hotline if I don't know if some
people are still listening now this the
very end but if you you know what's it
like having children out there did you
have fear when you're thinking about
children what's that like you know maybe
hit the outline if you have a suggestion
or a thought regarding that how what
your fear of children was or if you had
an experience where you didn't embrace
your child at first you know maybe you
didn't you left the wife and child and
you got back with them later or the
husband and child and you got back with
them later or you know if somebody's had
an interesting parent experience
emotional parent experience or something
like that
yeah maybe share some of that you know
some of that spent on my mind and on my
heart nine eighty five six six four nine
five zero three
you guys take care man love you bye